it is susanne wegman she is
a leading scientist in neuroscience
hello mrs vickmann
nice to have you joining us you
are heading your own research group at
the german center for neurodegenerative
diseases such as alzheimer's
a widespread disease could you please
outline what is it that fascinates and
motivates you to investigate these
diseases
of course i mean many aspects of the
brain are very fascinating to
me and other researchers and i think
trying to understand the complexity of
the processes in the brain
challenges our own brain capacity and
this challenge kind of drives
me and others to do brain research
myself i'm very fascinated by
how small molecular changes so molecules
like proteins and nucleic acids
how small changes in these building
blocks can actually two detrimental
effects in the brain that then
cause memory loss and personality
changes
my focus in my science is on a protein
called tau and
tau is a protein that helps the nerve
cells to stabilize their long extensions
in the normal brain but in alzheimer's
disease and other
related diseases it starts to aggregate
and actually kills the nerve cells
how it does that we don't really know
and we are working hard
to lift the secret actually
[Music]
let's understand which other branches of
science
could benefit from your work and how do
you actually include
interdisciplinary perspectives in your
work as well
so in my beliefs bridging disciplines
is a huge opportunity for us to
accelerate alzheimer's disease and other
research areas and i think the future of
science is actually in collaborative and
interdisciplinary research myself
i'm also an interdisciplinary researcher
because my background is
actually in biotechnology and biophysics
of molecules and
only eight years ago in 2012 i went to
the u.s to boston to join brad hyman and
his lab to work
at massachusetts massachusetts general
hospital and have at med school on
alzheimer's disease so that's when i got
engaged with the disease and since two
years i'm now back here in berlin having
my own group and
doing a kind of hybrid research so we
are using
biochemistry biophysics but also looking
in human brain samples and using mouse
models of the disease to tackle
the questions that we are having and
to come to this your other question how
we basically feed in other branches of
science i think so
since we are operating at the interface
of basic science and translational
science for
therapy development we are feeding
with our results and ideas into drug
development and therapy development
and on the other hand my team and i were
getting
inspiration from all kind of other
science fields
so i think it's important to in order to
develop an interdisciplinary approach
you have to be
always alert about what's going on in
other research so that
manifests for example that i'm currently
reading up on new technologies on
other research fields like cancer
biology at the moment or
genomics and protein biophysics and so
on and so on
what are the technologies which could
push the
next breakthrough forward in this field
if i would know this i would i would get
funding and get all the best people to
work on this but
until then i think um i believe that
actually technology the new technologies
evolving can bring us quite forward
because they open new
pathways and new like views on on the
old problem alzheimer's disease so in
particular i think we need new disease
models
um new disease models going away from
mouse models a bit because
on other animal models because it
becomes quite clear that they are not
really mimicking the human brain
surprisingly or not and i think
new disease models could be all that
that are emerging and important are for
example human derived stem cell systems
such as organoids or so-called
mini-brains that can bring us in an
in vitro dish forward in this and
on the therapy side i think for
therapeutic approaches for inherited
diseases um there's definitely the new
the new com new gene therapy tools that
are developed are very important and
promising to get into human diseases for
inherited diseases and
for spontaneous occurring alzheimer's
disease and other
dementia diseases i think we have to
move towards more holistic combinatorial
diseases not just tackling one
aspect of the disease but the whole
thing
well it seems these kind of diseases are
a very complex
problem what are the key factors for
these diseases did you find new factors
so we found some interesting more
biophysical factors that could
open up a new research area um
what is since we work on molecules what
is
i think also very interesting finding in
the last decade is that a lot of
external factors are triggering dementia
or at least increase the risk for
dementia so
for example it matters what you eat how
much you move how much stress you have
that all influences your brain and your
risk for alzheimer's
and dementia the digestive system as an
example is connected to the brain
through the gut brain axis and with that
your your gut
microbiome so what you have in your
stomach is actually influencing your
brain function
this is a very interesting new field
which is emerging now
we also know now that cardiovascular
system fitness so
is really helping your brain to maintain
for a longer time its function so that
means you have to have good nutrition
you have to move a lot
walk the stairs instead of taking the
elevator and
do not smoke no too much alcohol and no
bad nutrition even pollution air
pollution is making an
impact on your brain and i think with
those
um easy to and to change habits and we
can already um
improve our brain function for the
berlin science week you have
choosed a quite unusual way to
communicate your
topic you are hosting a short theater
play
followed by a discussion why is that
so first one is state it's not really my
idea so i'm just
get sucked into this and i really like
the idea that's why i'm taking part in
this
so the idea for the play dust invite me
for them has no it's by juan clara the
piece
and the idea came from christa muller
who is a
who is a retired actress who was
inspired by the piece when she saw it
and wanted to play it herself
in part to challenge her own aging brain
which i find very interesting
approach for this and the other main
person in this is
um the director of course franz damian
who set that very nicely this
interesting piece
into a living room setting so it becomes
very approachable for people
and the story is about a mother who
loses her memory and then there's this
daughter who has all these like
questions about the past and
yeah i think you should all see it it's
a very very interesting play yeah
it sounds very inspiring thank you so
much susanna wigman for
this interview thanks a lot